I heard this crazy story I don't know if
it's true but it's about yes with you
with sod so the first time you saw the
Rolling Stones they were doing blues
music at like a little was it like a pub
or theater what was what was it oh a
place called ilai Island it was a little
Ballroom in twickingham and there was 12
people there 12 people 12 people and
Mick's girlfriend was a girl called
Chrissy shrimpton who's a sister of the
great model Jean shrimpton and my
girlfriend his girlfriend were friends
and he said come and see my singer my
boyfriend he's a singer said my
boyfriend's a singer too so I went over
there and watched and there was
literally nobody there and they were all
sitting on stools playing you know but
they were doing like blues music yeah oh
yeah yeah Brian Jones was in the Bandon
and then within six months to a year
bash that was it they took off I mean
yeah those moments are just so cool like
once again like you busking and people
not knowing and then you sitting there
and not knowing like what that band
would become yeah the bles Britain was a
big thing so that's where that's where I
started as well the playing little clubs
playing blue stuff cuz that's what we
all heard that's it was a thing we you
know that you got daning makes such an
impact yeah like here like there's a lot
of music you just listen to do for fun
but not much that I mean feels like
really moves you yeah or that's what I
like to listen
[Music]
[Applause]
to thank you guys y'all have a great
night I'm going
home